all right destiny
destiny where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
where am i born where are you from
originally um from la and vegas las
vegas and tell me about your family
growing up both your mom and dad
no um just my mom my mom's side of the
family for the most part
my father was in prison
from
the age of one until
the age of 14 turning 15
and then uh
[Music]
he was in prison for
um he was in prison for um
uh
what do you call it identity
fraud
yeah uh he he he did 15
for that and
um
[Music]
he when he got out he was
um
so eager to
find me and
i remember like
literally walking up the stairs from
school and my mom's in front of me and
when her butt moved out the way i seen
this guy looks just like me and i got
scared
i had ran underneath her legs and i was
like she said what's wrong with you i
said
he has my face he has my face
i was so scared to touch him or just
look at him you know and
and you know i
i
hate that we never
got a chance to grow up
with each other you know but
you know he um
he's my inspiration he's the reason why
i have
mentality as it like
my mental smarts you know and
like how i can
continuously hold a conversation even if
i'm
drugged up or depressed or whatever i
can still
focus on
generating like something positive or
like some kind of message
or even to put together the perfect
sentence you know
he's the reason you have your dad's
personality and his looks i think so i
think so yeah i mean i will hope so
um
i i notice i have my i feel my mom's
little traits too you know
um
probably like my mom's sexy swagger you
know a little bit um
um
like some of her features you know
but for the most part
i have his skin you know she she feel
like
that when she looks at me that you know
she see him
and
you know i just recently
figured out after all these
all these years of
like
trying to like
go back to her and find her i was like
you know
it's a shame that you know my my mom
couldn't go to the funeral or my dad
passed away she's like i didn't want to
go i said why
she's like why would i want to go to
some man's funeral that forced me to
have a kid
and i said what do you mean by that
she's like
oh you think i wanted to have you and
i'm like
why wouldn't you want to help me you
know
so you know as she as me and her
drinking together this was just like
last year and she's like
telling me like these little stories and
i had i had
put two and two together you know and i
was like what
so you mean to tell me that
you know you you you didn't want to have
me
he made you have me
and
he named me from in the prison
so
you know that kind of like left me like
feeling violated like i was forced to
love the wrong parent you know what i
mean
because she was the one left over to
raise me you know
um
i feel like i know i know she did the
best that she could
you know i do know that but you know as
far as
me getting like
the ultimate education on how to be an
adult and
you know learning how to drive and [ __ ]
like you know getting my own apartment
you know stuff like that getting married
you know i i have a strong
feeling that that's all because of her
because she didn't
because she she thinks i look like him
you know so she wants him to pay
so she you know he's dead now so
the the only the only closest thing to
him is me you know so
whatever whatever
you know she she feels like when she's
when she's looking at me she she thinks
that it's him
so you know that's why at an early age
of 18 she let any guy who ever came back
to get me that's why she let me you know
she let me go with the dude and you know
i was homeless
at an early age and
um
how would you describe your childhood in
general
as a
like what like when you were younger
um
i was more happy
you know um
i felt like the little princess you know
even though he wasn't there you know i
still felt
like
you know like how the baby gets whatever
they want you know
like you know i feel i still felt
special
i had my mom and her sisters um used to
own a couple of foster homes
so a lot of foster kids i was raised
around and i shared my room with and
toys
and um
you know we
they they made us believe that we were
brothers and sisters you know so
um
at the time you know as i'm growing up
i'm like
mad because i have to share my toys and
stuff and i gotta be the yellow ranger
not the pink ranger you know but you
know at that time i was mad you know but
now it's like okay well that's probably
why they were there because
you know i didn't i i'm her only child
so
when i got older and i'm like fighting
these little
you know life tribulations and [ __ ] like
that you know i noticed that
having no sister or brother in the
background of you is very very difficult
it gets
very lonely
you
crawl into a very
you crawl into a deeper depression
because there's nobody there to reach in
there to help you come out you know and
you
you don't you think lesser people will
understand you
because
you don't have a relative you know to
share with you or
feel the experiences with you at the
same time if if there's somebody around
you at the time
that sees you during this time then
you're lucky you know what i'm saying
because then when you see the person
later on you'd be like oh you remember
that time when i was you know then they
know what you talking about you know but
you know but you know it's just have
having them to be with you know
with no
with no child you know most of these
women are out here with their
their kid like in their early teens or
they just coming up growing up in high
school and
you know knowing that i could have had
about two football teams already
you know and now one of them made it you
know that's like
it's like damn you know well i don't i
don't think that would have happened if
you know my dad was here you know so
you know or if if i had a brother or
sister with me you know because they
would probably help me take care of
myself better you know but how the hell
was i supposed to know you know i didn't
know how to do too much or nothing you
know i just
i don't know i just i guess i kind of
just like
like
um took everything step by step you know
that that's the first thing you know
take everything
little little by little step by step
you know if you can't walk yet you need
to start crawling and then you know and
then you know you sometimes you got to
hold on to stuff you know to walk you
know
um
you know but you know gradually you you
tend to start walking on your own you
know sometime
yeah i've been i've been in the point
where i've been actually knocked off of
my feet
and i was in the hospital for
about 28 days
exactly it's you know that's crazy i was
in the hospital for exactly 28 days and
the 20 the number 28
[Music]
is the day my father had passed away and
i was in a coma for
for i think 13 days
and
after i woke up i didn't know who i was
i don't remember who i was you know i
was like
um
i had to like they they found out who i
was and they wrote my name on the board
the name was making me say my name every
day to try to make me remember but
you know i was like
pretending to remember so they could let
me out the hospital
but what were you in the hospital for
um
um
metro
police have found me in a building
and uh they they said i was unconscious
i was um
but naked i had um
i had uh
pee and feces all over me and uh i was
they did a test you know a
rape kit test and they found three
different siemens and
i honestly i don't i don't really
remember too much of that i do remember
when nate when the police came and they
was like hey
uh
do you know where you at and i i looked
at him i turned around i said uh
get the [ __ ] out of my house you know i
don't know why i said that but and i was
just i just remember feeling really
tired
it was real it was so hot it was like
110 degrees out there
and
i was waiting on this guy to come
and bring me my backpack
that's all that's all i remember
and then i remember again waking up in
in the ambulance
and they were sticking um
the
what do you call that um
you know the tubes do uh
iv yeah there you go they were they
stuck
two here
and then they stuck to here
and then um
they had like some tube thing at my nose
and
then i think i woke up another time
when i felt a pinch i felt something
really sharp on my neck
and then and then i remember waking up
and
the it was two doctors one was holding
my head down and he's like hurry up
she's feisty she's a fighter
uh-huh it's okay man it's okay you can
go back to sleep and i was like no no
they were putting some kind of they
called it a sleeve some kind of sleeve
or something like that
and i guess it was for the eye for iv
and um
yeah i had i had ivs everywhere i looked
like
something off of
um what is that one movie um
um
the something master and you know the
guy with the
thorns all in his head
so so you started working the streets
when
um
at the age of
12 13.
yeah how did that start
um well you know my mom
came and told me that she was short on
rent and that you know we were going to
be homeless and on the street if
she didn't get the rent paid and
um
that's all i remember i mean you know
after that i had um
have you had sex before that
no not sex per se more like
um
like little kitty stuff you know like
touching each other or something like
that i put you out there to make money
right
yeah do you remember your first date at
12 years old
i do actually
i do um
he was a older white male um
he
paid 600 dollars to
eat [ __ ]
at first it started out as 200 and then
i remember something about
my mom saying
or my my mom's sis my mom's younger
sister saying something like
every five minutes he passed you do make
him
charge him 20
or something like that and then
um every five minutes it went by it was
like i was like 20
20 20 and it got to up to like 600 and
something dollars and
then he was like um
he was like come on five more minutes
just five more minutes i was like 20 20
20.
he's like
ah i ran out of money um
i i just i just need to go to the atm
and i said well whenever you ready
know where to find me you know but until
then
i gotta stop
you know i have to go
and he's like do you have a pimp i said
i sure do so
if if you don't stop now he's gonna come
he's gonna come and get you and then
beat me up i know you don't want that
now he's like no we don't want that no
we don't want that um okay okay uh
that's fine um okay can i meet you same
here
here again tomorrow same time i said
sure
no problem and
i did
i i think i met him for like almost a
week and then i think he had set me up
with the police
yeah and i got caught
with the juvenile for that [ __ ]
i was scared shitless they they put me
in there for like seven days
said no it was uh
it was um
seven to ten days i spent
i spent
nine days and or
ten days and and
no i'm sorry
ten nights and nine days in there
something like that
and i was scared shitless
because it was it was like older
like high school women in there they
were they were taking females [ __ ]
like it was nothing like they was
purposely making you drop the soap and
stuff you know
like you know and then don't have like
you better you better get a cell by
yourself you know because they were they
were like going like
yeah i went down right there and i was
like
whoa
who's doing this
this these were the women that were in
the in the in the juvenile detention
really
yeah they they do not play around with
little little coochies and they they be
on all of them it's not safe anywhere
no even with your mom at all
right yeah you can say that
yeah she's she's probably
she's probably
the main creator of of this
um
life that you're in yeah how long you
been doing it
on and off
on and off
all my life how do you know 31
31 yeah i just turned 31 do you have
kids
no
i don't think i can have any
so i'm probably like the last bloodline
of my legacy
you know
so i that's why you know i tend to put
this out for
young women to understand that you know
they're not alone
you know and you know you don't
need
some
guy trying to put you out there you
don't need
so-called pimp
because you know
if they're not taking care of you
if they're not helping you eat if
they're not putting a roof over your
head or providing for you what you need
to you know continue to strive for a
better life even if you're not living it
at least strive for it then
he's not [ __ ] you know you can do all
that on your own sometimes they're
disguised as boyfriends and sometimes
they're yeah yeah but they're getting
high yeah
yeah that that's where it starts at you
know they they sell the same drug that
you smoke you know i'm saying that's how
it starts off you know and then and then
you just be locked in from that from
that day forward like me and the the guy
that i was in a bad relationship with
that's how
we started i was in a relationship with
him for over seven years
and you know it would seem like you know
we would have a lot of
history together you know
to the point where we should be married
you know zan but you know he he's
he's dealing with life itself you know
he's one of those type of people where
you know he he's lost people that he
loved to the point where
now he doesn't he's not really so sure
what he wants to be or
neither is he comfortable in his own
skin you know
and um
you know we we we've always
been distant
with each other to the point where
like
we can sleep in the same bed and not
have sex at all you know
but at the same time you know as far as
being around each other
like during the day it's impossible
either one of us has to be asleep or one
of us has to be gone in order for us to
get along with each other
because we we will like he me and him
has fought each other like we was two
sumo wrestlers okay
like really real [ __ ] like i i've that's
how he's how i learned how to fight
because i had to fight him for the last
six years of my life
and you know
you know i feel like you know i always
told him i said you know i hate you i
you know i wish i never met you you know
but truthfully you know i'm glad i
didn't meet him because you know he
helped me be a stronger person you know
and
you know
sometimes i'd be like i can't i can't do
this without him because i don't i don't
have my driver's license and stuff like
that so
you know i don't i don't you know i feel
like i'm at the age to the point where i
don't if i don't if i don't have it
already
it's probably not going
is sl slim to none chances of me getting
it
by the time i do take interest in i'll
probably be
60 70 some years old you know
i don't think they i think they cut off
your your
driver's license at a certain age now i
think like when you get like 80
something or something like that i think
they just come back yeah so are you
staying in motels yes i am yeah
have you had tim's
have you had pimps
have i had what tim's have i hadn't
before yeah um
not willingly
not willingly you know i've been um
i've been tooking against my will over
four times you know uh
one one time it was a group thing
um no
two times it was a group thing
um the other two times
were like by single-handed like a
single-handed guy you know but the other
the first two were
um
it was a woman and and
um a group of her
so-called family friends
and then um
the other ones
was three guys
one
one of the dudes was fresh out like he
was really really really fresh out he
was still in the halfway house so he had
two other guys to come and watch me
and
they would do shift change to make sure
i didn't run away and [ __ ] like that you
know
so it was always against your will
yeah
i was always blessed
i was always blessed
by
the power of god and his angels to get
away from it
and then
my dad's mentality because
sometimes i was smart enough to talk my
way out of it you know
it would take a long time now like these
guys would be driving me off
city to city to city city in california
one time this guy he drove me from
las vegas all the way to sacramento
okay this was like almost a year and a
half ago
and
he was he drugged me up with um fentanyl
and the date rape drug
in my coffee and
i was just supposed to go to a
transitional program i was tired you
know i was trying to do better
you know do the right thing for my mom
and stuff you know try to get out of
this
type of picture you know
and boom he just [ __ ] he just
snatched me up
and and then
he was when he came to pick me up from
the bus station he's like here i got you
a coffee from 7-eleven i was like oh
thank you i needed that i'm tired i was
falling asleep on the bus i need this
man i drunk like this much of it
next thing i know
i'm literally stretched all the way out
in his back seat
i looked up where the motel 6.
he's nowhere in the car i didn't know
what was going on
i just remember feeling so tired i was
like you know what i don't know where
i'm at i don't think i should get out
walking because it was freezing cold
i'm gonna just wait till he gets back so
you know i went back to sleep
and then i woke up and we were
it was it was um it was another guy in
the car and
we were stopped in some apartment
complex
i didn't know where it was at i'm
thinking that we're still like in las
vegas
and we'll come to find out he drove all
the way to sacramento the whole time i
was in in the cars knocked out
i don't know
i could have died and came back for all
i know you know that that's how much he
had put in the coffee
and um
the next the next day
the other guy in the car
he kept telling me that um well he kept
asking me questions at first
how much money can you make if if if we
was to put you out on the street right
here how much money can you make in like
in a day in an hour i'm like i don't
know i don't look i don't sell [ __ ] i
don't do that anymore
sorry you know
so he gets mad
he starts talking to the other guy and
stuff
and then um
he's like telling this guy
man we should have her go in in in the
old place where we worked that didn't
i got a pig mask in the back
and i'm like
so
he's like
if we give you these directions
if you if you want to go home you need
to you better follow these directions if
we give you these directions i say okay
no problem i can do it i'll do whatever
you sure no problem
i can do it you know
so he gives me this mass this is a
massive pig
and he's like
i used to work at the store i'ma write
i'm gonna draw a blueprint out of where
the cash
at i said
cash register
why you can't do it you got more muscle
than me you know he's like
[ __ ] you said you want to go home right
i was like yeah
okay yeah you made a point you got a
good point there all right okay so
which door do i gotta go into you know
he's like
the other guy's like no this is not
gonna work this is not gonna work let's
not have her do it now she's gonna [ __ ]
it up she's gonna [ __ ] her up
he's like no i don't care let's just
let's just risk it she can get away with
it and
he didn't end up doing it he got
he had got the upper hand he he felt
like i was too
nerdy-ish you know i was too square to
do it like i was going to get caught or
something
and um you know what i probably was i
probably would have got caught on
purpose just because you know i was i
would have seen that as a way to get out
you know
are drugs a part of your life
of course
of course i i i probably
i probably would have probably
definitely killed myself if it wasn't
for drugs
i can be honest about that
definitely
it helps you forget about all the things
you've been through
it numbs my body
when i'm not on drugs i just cry
even sometimes when i'm on drugs i still
cry but it's less painful you know i can
control the tears a little bit
you know but
when i'm when i'm not when i'm totally
sober you know i feel
just like
i feel like there's no point you know or
i feel like
like i'm a lost cause or like
it's
like
like why why i couldn't go with my dad
or i'll have the feeling to want to go
find him and leave leave him
you know because you know after
discovering that you know i've been
loving the wrong parent all this time
you know
that makes me just
have no
no reason to stay here i have no kids
you know
my mom learned to love me so that's
that's not really pure
i mean so you know and then
the only thing i have really is like my
cousins
and
i have my godmother you have friends
i don't know i don't think so i mean
what do you define as friends i mean
you think there's a lot of people on the
down low
[ __ ] yeah
all the time man you you know
these people aren't even on the down low
anymore they're so
into it
they're walking around in pure daylight
like they done drunk vampire
anti-vampire juice or something and they
could now walk in the sunlight because
you know and and and they're they're
proud of it too you know
i seen this guy on the way over here he
was walking with a wig on
he had all some makeup still had his
beard
okay i mean like a full
bushy rick ross looking beard okay
he had he had a bra on with titties but
he had cans empty um
um you know you know the um
you know the canned goods the the home
they get the homeless he had empty cans
of that sitting up his titties
okay and then
um looked like some kind of
some kind of balloon ball his ass okay
and he walking proud of it i said i was
like
what the hell
you know but you know as crazy as crazy
as he looks
he's probably he's probably one of the
most realist people out here that
probably would help you out you know
that's the
weirdest part about it because you know
it'd be it'd be them type of people that
that looked crazy as hell outside but
they'd probably be
pro they'd probably be like just the
right person that would help you or
that that you would need to you know
like
like sometime when you feel tired you
need
a help with yourself
or to help finish something you know and
that probably would be the person to
clean it up for you you know
with no problem no no questions asked
you know you know we want no money for
it he just i do it you know
you know
so you know and you know we
when we see this type of [ __ ]
we'd be looking at like uh
you better not bring your ass over here
you know you be like
don't come over here here you go here
you go there you go
you don't want to touch it or nothing
you know so
you know i don't you know i don't i
don't discriminate
you know i'm very
i'm very known about
you know being
bisexual
i mean my my
my grandparent
actually produced that in my head
for it to be very okay
i later on learned like in my late 20s
that that was bad
you know like as far as like you know
being
being touched as a little kid and stuff
like that i didn't know that was bad
until
like my mid 20s late 20s you know
that that was
not good you know that happened to you
at age
um
i was like
well as i since i can remember
probably i would say the age of three or
four
but it could have been
before then even you know
who is that doing that to you
my grandfather
my grandpa my mom's
my mother's father
being out now since my auntie passed
away
now i don't have anywhere to go you know
so
i had to start getting motels paying for
motels now i'm just like hustling every
single day to keep the motel
and it's very tiring because i can't
call for help i can't call on my uncles
and my aunties anymore anymore because
you know they they're they're all gone
you know they
they died from
from having a diabetic episode all the
way to
to
being um
alcohol alcoholic and then
my auntie she died from the corona
and
you know i still i still kind of think
that maybe
you know they're just labeling that as
the corona it could have been something
that happened
from when i was
kidnapped or something you know
somebody could have made it may have
you know looped back around and went
over there and tried to you know
make me make me come back for to pay
them more money you know as far as i
know you know
so you know i you know i that's why i
feel like i shouldn't
like i i
i i understand why she doesn't want to
come back you know because if that's the
case then you know i wouldn't want to
come back either
for what why would i want to
have all that heaviness on my heart
going outside every day you know
unless i start a family out here you
know but
i don't know if i want my family around
these kind of people
i want my family around you know like in
a house and
you know green grass and stuff you know
i don't want my kids looking at no
crackheads smoking dope in the back of
the dumpster you know
i don't think i want that you know
i mean it would be educational for them
but
you know i don't want them going down
that road so
you know all right all right destiny
thank you so much for sharing your story
you're welcome
i appreciate you
thank you very much thank you so much
very interesting thank you
you